Jeff horn the new wo world welterweight
champion who was kind enough to join me
right here in studio in person on the
Rich Eisen show good to see a champ how
are you I'm good thank your right eye is
still bloody from from the fight so good
yeah I'm so good that that blood inside
why I know it doesn't hurt Thanks
anything else no that's it that's about
it huh
so you heard what Teddy Atlas had to say
and I'm sure you've heard what so many
others had to see even gone back and
forth with them on social media what do
you say to those who believe that you
did not win that fight against Manny
Pacquiao a couple weeks ago there's not
much I can say these the people that
aren't going to believe it
usually the ones that are going to
continue not to believe so I guess I
felt like I won the fight so that that's
all I can it's all really matters is I
feel like I want Ned at what point in
the fight do you think you know you had
this fight in your gloves do you think
so after the first half of the fights of
36 rounds I felt like I'd won majority
of the first rounds and then I finished
the fight off strong so I feel like that
was enough to win it now when you're
standing there you expecting to hear
your name called by Michael buffer right
there not necessarily because I knew it
was going to be hard to get a decision
against Manny and always expected and
pictured for myself if it went down to a
decision I probably wouldn't get it but
I was I was very very happy even in your
hometown I mean even younger your home
country I mean if it's still Manny's
money if he's very hard legend to beat
it and that's what I thought the judges
were going to be watching many more than
myself but they were very fair now do
you think you would have won this fight
if it was in the Philippines Jeff it's
same judges yeah um I don't know I think
the the judge the judging what happened
was very fair so I guess it was the same
people there in the Philippines it would
have been the same result after the
ninth round the ref we could hear in the
ESPN coverage told you you know show me
something
essentially you're not showing me enough
is what I took it to mean did you take
that warning to mean that yeah yeah I
was
kind of surprised it was my worst round
for sure the round nine and he came up
to me in the break and said show me
something or else I'm going to stop this
fight and I was just like hey hold on a
second I'm saying
I'm not too bad like I felt pretty much
fully recovered by then when I sat down
and had a few seconds and so I wanted to
make sure I showed him something in
exterior and the Jeff warned the Jeff
supported horn the champ of the WBO
world welterweight world joining us here
on the Rich Eisen show and because I
mean with that sentiment that the
referee was communicating to you at that
point in time I think as you saw on
social media afterwards and we heard
from Teddy Atlas that was a belief that
was being shared by a large population
that was consuming the fight at the time
so how do you square all of that with
the fact that you have the belt and
there was enough folks who thought
something else yes yes well I guess it
was a it was the hardest round for me in
that fart was round 9 and I guess the
best comeback story there could be in a
boxing match where where the person that
got knock knock down all all got knocked
around a bit in one round they had bad
bad round come back and win the fight
well now you after the independent
review results were revealed you put
them on your I believe was Facebook and
other social media accounts and there
was a group of individuals that you
targeted to see yeah in particular may I
read this list yes okay are you where
this Chris Brockman of this list are you
aware of this I'm not here the folks
uuuuu person specifically targeted
samuel l.jackson okay Kobe Bryant Oh
Stephen a Smith Teddy Atlas and Aaron
Rodgers why that famous simply quintet
Joe I guess so those few people were
ones that thought I'd lost the fight so
it was just for their information this
is what the scores actually were did any
of them respond no not that I know of
anyway but I mean how about the fact
that you're you're looking down at your
responses
and Kobe Bryant is saying this stuff
about you look it's just for instance
just throwing I mean he's pretty
world-renowned Sam Jackson yeah I don't
know I guess there were many fans so I
didn't know anything about me and they
saw that rad 9 and they saw a bit of a
fight and they didn't want to think that
I'd want to are you a fan of Sam Jax's
work yeah good I'm just trying to see if
there's a mutual admiration side it
gives you such obviously a fan of your
work in a way one way to put it
you don't have a comment on snakes on a
plane or really okay um I'm just trying
to throw that out there and how Aaron
Rodgers are you you know of him you know
still him
so how come you you tagged him just cuz
you you heard he's a famous guy pretty
late actually wasn't even the person to
put that post up this comes out see now
that's an honest answer who is honored
to sue as a as my team so for my
management team okay without because
Stephen a Smith that doesn't really
crack the Brisbane nah you know any
stuff our heart okay so now let's just
quickly talk with Jeff Ward Jeff the
warning horn here on the Rich Eisen show
how did you get started in this whole
crazy mixed-up boxing well Jeff Lucas I
went to school got got into some fights
at school got picked on a fair bit came
out of it second-best a majority of
those so I thought coming out of school
will be a lot worse if I'm not getting
picked on or beat up so I was like I've
got to learn how to defend myself here
and that's what drew me to the boxing
gym and that's when you started getting
in there and starting to figure out how
to defend yourself exactly so but when
did you start to think I could do this
professionally well I walked into the
gym at 18 years old and it probably took
about a year or so before I actually
thought well my trainer recognized he
goes I think you've got what it takes
like to get to the Olympics in about
four years time and be a world champion
one day and I was really wanting to do
professional sport as a living and he
knew that and I was tossing out between
playing rugby league and and boxing is
you've got to give this a crack and
there I did and had
my first fight at 20 years old and then
you did make it to the Olympics right
you were in London at London Games and
so what is it like getting in the ring
with Manny Pacquiao amazing experience
but like the whole build-up seeing money
across to me on the table talking to him
having faith face offs with him but in
the ring that completely switched off
for me I was just another person I had
to had to be or else I was going to be
to overawed by who was standing across
from me now did when you do the
face-to-face with him I mean have you
ever done a face-to-face with a fighter
and go wow that guy really needs to take
shower just to you know I've always
thought that because I mean you're
really so close to the guy no I've never
thought that before I ever I suppose
you're only thinking about one thing
that's just looking in their eyes and
seeing what they're what they're
thinking
Charlie rake of all I would do is like
if if I did that with you or anybody I
would just say this is the stupidest
silliest thing I've ever done to another
human being and when can this end
because this is particularly awkward I
don't want to blink because you know I
don't want this guy to think that I'm a
blinker I mean honestly I guess that
maybe I don't have what it takes on that
front no I just don't feel like that a
bit and when I did that with Manny
Pacquiao vs. so I couldn't help but
smile I could not like yeah right I
could not believe I was staring Manny
Pacquiao in the face I was like this is
actually going to happen this is
actually going to happen because we saw
McGregor and Mayweather yesterday the
ng-repeat
we're traveling your sony of that
craziness that went down yesterday and
i'm just thinking that these guys are do
they genuinely dislike each other do you
genuinely have to work up dislike for an
opponent i mean i don't know i don't
think everyone does it depends on your
personality but i'm just doing a job in
there I'm just doing what I need to do
to win a fight don't need to dislike the
person but if they want to try and make
themselves this dislike hmm then I will
do you have you ever tried MMA you ever
try not okay so what do you think of the
mayweather mcgregor fight I think it
should be an easy win for Mayweather
it's a boxing fight if it was the USC
fight would be an easy win some
yeah it's just the way so you think it's
just as simple as it's his ring not
McGregor's ring it's his art form not
McGregor's and that's the end of that
exactly but that's basically what's
going to happen in mayweather doesn't
want to be hit by Conor McGregor by
punches he's not going to be here the
only thing is if he throws some type of
wild punch that he's never seen before
but I think Mayweather seen everything a
couple more minutes here with Jeff the
Hornet horn the WBO world welterweight
champion where is the belt right now the
belt is getting guarded safely by my dad
in Australia so the belt is not on this
continent not in this hemisphere
essentially brockman am i right on the
hemisphere front southern hemisphere
thank you okay are we in the southern
hemisphere no we're in the northern room
the northern home there's information uh
so it's not even in this hemisphere no
your dad is guarding yeah how big is
your dad okay he's not that big he's
pretty small so you better come at him
correct is he scratchy I mean like what
if it what he's just my look at it and
so what is the status of a rematch now
there's a rematch clause between you and
Manny Pacquiao
yeah the conversations right now it's
all up to Pacquiao at the moment in his
boat we're just waiting to see what he's
going to say he's been offered it he's
got the rematch clause we're just
waiting to see what he decide what if he
says it's got to be in the Philippines
I'd prefer not to be because I think I
might get destroyed over there by
Filipinos but do you mean just on the
streets yeah if I feel right I think
they like me very much
but in all seriousness you do you think
you could get a fair fight in the
Philippines I don't know it depends on
the judges I suppose it should be the
same like if the judges are fair then it
should be a fair fair decision so you're
waiting here for Manny Pacquiao you
prefer did you have a preferred location
yeah definitely oh I'd love to fought
again in in Australia and Brisbane
especially I'm sure I can go from my bed
to the for what if we you know we could
move some furniture around here oh yeah
how about here yeah why not we would
we're not big God will fit in here I
mean we've got a cafeteria crossed away
we an endless supply of water why I mean
we can keep you hydrated yep
yeah yeah yes I mean you see look at all
the people that are right just walking
right behind us we had a good crowd
together and okay call the I don't even
know the authorities I like it like
there are really well they'll probably
sit it again gqo events until train okay
okay yeah
there they go those are then the
governing body will get move we'll see
if they answer the phone the big calls
here are you going to the ESPYs yes okay
all right okay whatever who are you
gonna meet well tonight were you're
looking forward to seeing I don't even
what if you run into Kobe Bryant oh uh
hello I've seen you before I'm pretty
sure I saw him at the Olympics Stephen a
Smith's going to be there uh Aaron
Rodgers should be there and Sam Jackson
is a former host of the ESPYs you might
run into damn near every bunny outfit
Teddy Atlas is going but good to see you
congratulations Thank You Aaron you bet
that's Jeff horn the WBO world
welterweight champion of the world here
on the Reg Oz so Rich Eisen shown
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy